es ist die kindheits beichte eines ex
rtl dschungelkönigs und dsds sänger joey
heinle wird als sechsjähriger zwei jahre
mit psychopharmaka behandelt weil er
seinen vater zu aufgeweckt war die das
medikament ritalin ritalin würz kindern
mit adhs verabreicht dass die symptome
sind da konzentrationsschwäche
impulsives verhalten und gesteigerte
unruhe das ist ritalin isolierte joy und
machte ihn zu einem außenseiter wie er
sagt noch zwei jahren konnte die mutter
dem elend ein ende setzen
die spiele wurden in denen chlor
entsorgte veröffentlichte gerade seine
biographie seine autobiografie sein
leben seine kindheit bis heute und wir
wollen sprechen über diese beichte diese
kindheits beichte mit die händler jetzt
live ihr bei bild herr eine ganz
herzlich willkommen hier bei bild.de sie
bekamen zwei jahre
ritalin hallo hey was war der grund
dafür ritalin zu bekommen hatten sie den
adhs nein ich hatte kein areal ist es
natürlich so dass ich bei den ein oder
anderen ärzten natürlich gewesen bin
weil ich halt einfach sehr aufgeweckter
menschen natürlich auch gewesen bin
aber es ließ sich dann zum schluss
heraus gegeben hat dass ich halt
natürlich wenig gegen die mit diesen
symptomen zu tun da wird also die ärzte
haben auch gesagt er hat überhaupt gar
nichts und das ist einfach so dass das
ganze sich bei mir natürlich so
ausgelöst hat dass ich in der schule
wirklich total still gewesen bin kein
aufgeweckt am menschen mehr gewesen bin
sondern wirklich nur noch schwer gewesen
hat und stundenlang die bank angeschaut
habe die verbindung natürlich zu meinen
mitschülern war auch nicht irgendwie
mehr da da haben sich auch keine
freundschaften mehr irgendwie gebildet
oder sonstwer weil ich halt irgendwie
ganz anders war
wie anders waren sie denn wie hat sich
dieses medikament auf sie ausgewirkt
dass das war halt so dass ich wirklich
das gefühl hatte irgendwie die ganze
zeit ruhig zu sein dass ich habe ich war
irgendwie war keine motivation irgendwie
da und wollte mal was so dass ich halt
abends dann irgendwie am esstisch saß
und wirklich dann irgendwie was weiß ich
zwei drei stunden die wand angeschaut
habe und natürlich hat sich das
medikament auch bei mir so ausgelöst
dass wir auch schlecht davon geworden
ist also ich habe wirklich nicht
vertragen und versucht immer wieder
gesagt ich möchte das überhaupt nicht
nehmen und so und ja diese übelkeit ist
natürlich da gewesen dass man sich
vielleicht auch ein paar mal in der
schule dann tatsächlich auf dem schulklo
übergeben hat oder so konnte
eigentlich ist es eine botschaft in
meiner biografie um den leuten einfach
auch zu zeigen dass man eigentlich die
kinder so nehmen sollte diese sind genau
aber das klingt danach als hätten sie
diese zwei jahre ganz schön gelitten
ihre mutter hat dem ganzen dann ein ende
gemacht warum denn erst nach zwei jahren
also ich sag mal so
damals war es ja so dass dieses
medikament ja noch nicht so krass erfolg
gewesen ist und ich sage euch gibt es
hier kein irgendwie großartig die schuld
auch mein papa nicht und meiner mom auch
nicht ich glaube einfach dass das damals
auch eine eine gewisse überforderung
gewesen ist und das ist einfach ich
glaube einfach nur überforderung gewesen
und generell einfach dass sie dann das
eben gemacht haben und ich meine das
habe ich einfach nicht gut vertrag und
ich finde einfach man sollte die kinder
wirklich so eben diese sind das ist das
allerwichtigste eine klare aussage eine
klare forderung von joye händler
in seiner autobiografie gerade
veröffentlicht ganz herzlichen dank für
das gespräch herr bei bild